martin biron hélène buzzati michel
surgit bonsoir bonsoir
alors je vais vous faire entendre
monsieur legault qui en montre à la
carte du québec audi a5 région qui nous
inquiète qui pourraient retomber au
rouge en voulant dire le sous texte
c'est fort possible messieurs dames si
on fait pas attention collectivement
qu'on vienne c'est pas quelque chose qui
est exclu du tout on pourrait même
revenir vous voir dans deux jours
en conférence de presse on écoute
monsieur legault vous pourriez resserré
ou dans leur range ça pourrait aller
plus loin que que le rouge actuelle on
pourrait revenir au rouge qu'on avait à
20 pieds au couvre-feu à utah par
exemple mais à certains endroits d'un
non lieu d'un couvre-feu à 6 heures à 18
heures pot instinct nos prévisions
montrent qu'on est à l'intérieur de nos
capacités mais la tendance est mort est
donc faut que ça arrête d'augmenter dans
ces cinq régions leur sac mentent pas
montréal se demande dans ces cinq
régions l'heure
marten message qui était clair à ce qu'
il sera entendu
oui bah écoutez si venus temps avant
cette déclaration la pendant le point de
presse
il a fallu le questionner le premier
ministre il voulait surtout servir un
avertissement mais je peux vous dire que
ça tergiverse beaucoup dans l'entourage
du premier ministre avec les gens de
santé publique
et c'est vraiment pas exclu que d'ici la
fin de la semaine il y avait d'autres
consignes on s'attend demain dans la
région de québec spécifiquement à une
augmentation substantielle des nombres
de cannes beaucoup des pistes et à
québec et on se rend compte que la
situation est explosive
on marche un peu sur un fil parce que en
même temps on a des confiné lol à
vendredi dernier notamment zone rouge
les salles de spectacle et jim
on n'a pas le goût de refaire mes mails
à l'idée du couvre-feu pour la période
de pâques l'un c'est dans l'air ok et au
couvre 1 photo l'entourent à 20h20 en
prison dans les cinq zones le sigle est
là qui sont sous surveillance au quai
jamais boire les chefs du québec souple
et les remettent une petite seconde
ça me permet de poser la question à
michel 6 à hélène bon ça c'est les
chiffres du québec ce qui entre
guillemets n'êtes pas là le plaidoyer de
monsieur legault c'est que les chiffres
au québec à reste relativement stable
oui augmentation des hospitalisations
qu'on aime pas voir mais regardons en
ontario d'avoir le détail de l'ontario
avec un taux de positivité très élevé
2336 cas d'hospitalisation on a
l'impression pour l'instant ça tient
mais la crainte du québec c'est que le
scénario était rien le surviennent
hélène tu as plus que a lancé comme
message monsieur trudeau aujourd'hui
rendit alors s'il vous plaît à pâques le
reste est longée vous oui et aussi le
problème c'est que on constate par
exemple aux soins intensifs que l'âge
des personnes qui y entrent commence à
diminuer et donc ces personnes ne sont
des côtes de soins beaucoup plus élevé
des adb donc on essaie de les sauver à
tout prix
donc il reste plus longtemps dans les
soins intensifs donc il y en a peut-être
moins qu'ils rentrent au jour le jour
mais accumulation qui se fait serein
plus une plus longue période de temps
d'où le problème là de congestion qui
peut survenir mais oui évidemment tous
les politiciens essaient de nous dire
subtilement de se tenir tranquille mais
on le sent bien les gens sont tannés
il y avait comme une espèce de
décroissance des mesures de confinement
le consent depuis quelques semaines et
donc tout le monde est parti sur cette
lancée là et là c'est ça qui est
difficile politiquement c'est de laisser
planer un retour vers l'arrière alors
que la vaccination va bon train
politiquement c'est une décision qui est
très douloureuse à prendre oui mes
chaussures jaunes a même vu un décalage
le décalage la distance qui se creusait
entre les conseils plus strict de la
place à l'ailé santé publique un peu
partout les médecins et la gouvernance
politique qui dit oui je veux bien je
vous entends mais moi faut que je sois
crédible auprès de la population aussi
marcher sur un fil de fer c'est
exactement dire ce que la santé publique
dit et d'autre part il ya le gouvernorat
qui semblait puis celui quand on est
dans un système comme le nôtre la les
députés ils ont l'oreille de leur
population il en parle au caucus de
cette affaire là et ça s'envole
ça fait partie de ce que le premier
ministre utilise comme informations pour
décider alors c'était fait
effectivement il y a des gens qui sont
très étonnés des conseils pâques pour
avoir le même effet que noël avait donné
une accélération des corps quand même
assez substantielle et on voit ce qui se
passe partout l'euro ce qui passe en
france on voit ce qui se passe en
ontario la troisième vague et la avoir
frappé fort et dont on peut pas être
complètement immunisé de barcelone et
politiquement ccc dangereux aussi parce
que on voit ce qui se passe en ontario
ici à québec
et si on ne confine pas assez et que ça
s'emballe le prix politique pour
monsieur legault
il pourrait apparaître le cas maintenant
il s'en est assez bien tiré mais là on
est en sortie de crise
probablement un mois l'a finalement
d'une forme de relative libération alors
il faut nous on veut pas manquer son
coup la cc ce qui est compliqué et vous
dit à noter un spectateur martin que de
ne pas s'étonner savez une annonce sur
un couvre-feu plutôt en général pour
pâques - sipa béton mais c'est dans
l'air et on attend de voir le dans les
prochains jours monde après m'en
souvenais soit demain soit je lui dis
bien évidemment c'est le second gilles
bon la vaccination ce qui ce qui nous
ramène à la vaccination
les malheurs d'astrazeneca n'aide pas
les américains d envoyer un million cinq
cent mille doses au canada mais là on
dit les 55 ans et - non on préfère que
non on suspend on avait dit au début
hélène que c'était les 65 ans et plus le
problème les gens sont avec raison on
peut mélanger on essaie de faire des
pédagogies croyez moi on passe des
heures à expliquer mais quand même
astrazeneca ça regarde pas bien monsieur
monsieur trudeau a voulu rassurer saunal
tableau les files vont arriver par clem
poche il jean se dit johnson aussi on
écoute monsieur trudeau puis je vous dis
bah voilà le tableau on a augmenté les
doses pour le 15 juin et johnson &
johnson ou il ya une dose qui va arriver
aussi on écoute m dû arriver à la fin
juin on parle d'avoir plus que 40
millions de doses de vaccins arrivée au
canada ce qui nous met en très bonne
situation pour dire qu'avant la fin de
l'été tout le monde au canada va pouvoir
être vacciné avec les deux dos et même
dépendamment de comment les provinces
distribuer ces vaccins c'est possible
que beaucoup de gens aient au moins leur
première dos à avant que l'été soit
vraiment lancé
l' été lancée le 21 juin hélène en
principe est donc on compte encore la
tullow malgré les revers de l'asfa
yennega on dit le calendrier tient en
fait oui tout à fait et le chiffre qu'il
faut retenir monsieur trudeau était un
peu approximatif l'eau mais on attend 44
millions de doses si la fin juin de ce
nombre là il y en a à peu près 4
millions qui viendraient d'astrazeneca
alors même si vous y soustrayez cessé
ces deux là un peu plus controversées ou
mal aimé ces jours-ci qu on est quand
même capable d'atteindre hub et
facilement la cible d'une première dose
à tous les canadiens qui le désirent ils
font réaliser le col et astrazeneca ont
en commun peu chanceux dans notre
malchance le fait que ce vaccin ait été
retardé dans l'approbation libre ça
prend du temps me recevoir
il représente à peu près 13 % de toutes
les deux on va voir dans le prochain le
prochain sur la plage
oui c'est ça alors la très vaste
majorité des vaccins céphise moderna et
au québec là juste pour ceux qui
s'interrogent les gens de 55 ans et
moins qui ont reçu une première dose
d'astrazeneca liliane seulement 6000
alors c'est un très petit nombre
et comme l'expliqué votre précédente et
on sait pas trop si on veut leur donner
une deuxième dose ce vaccin ou d'un
autre alors mais qui serait de quelqu'un
disait michel sait que lui recommande
encore de 6,6 on nous offre astrazeneca
pour une deuxième dose de dire oui à sa
et recommandera à ses parents la semaine
prochaine de prendre même la soirée
necas c'est ça qu'ils à parce que malgré
tout pour les gens de 60 ans et plus les
bénéfices sont largement supérieurs
on faible risque tous les vrais
spécifiquement le problème c'est pas ça
le problème c'est que les gens
commencent à ne plus avoir confiance en
soi rexel a et quand ils ont le choix
maintenant ok bien convoyeur on va voir
quelles sont les plages destin est
meilleur quand on prendra notre rade où
on va nous le dire
il s'inspire forme et qui est de plus en
plus de gens qui disent non moi je le
veux pas on savait avant on disait ben
rhodes 65 il faut là c'est le contraire
est bon pour les gens de 55 cm ordonnée
ceci c'est lui le plus drôle des as du
marketing depuis le nouveau concours
choisir ces personnes qui se retrouvent
là dedans et que le vrai danger c'est
que les gens ne veulent plus elle a fait
ouais mais pour ça que ce qu il n a dit
est important c'est une petite portion
de toutes les doses de vaccins qui
seront reçus finalement un petit
problème finalement parce qu'il y en a
tellement doses que finalement on peut
donner le choix aux gens et on ne sait
pas en favori et avec cela québec
s'apprêtait l'umq ont exécuté vous
voulez pas d'engin terrain reportage au
18 heures en mon tract dans certaines
régions il ya un problème de gens pour
donner les doses mais je vous avais posé
la question il ya quelques jours je
crois est-ce qu'on se retrouvera pas
avec des histoires comme ça
d'astrazeneca avec un manque de bras des
gens qui vont y aller à reculons pas mal
et ça les autorités ne veulent pas voir
son élève non effectivement mais moi je
vous fais une prédiction c'est le
problème qu'on va faire assez rapidement
c'est qu'on va voir beaucoup trop de
doses de vaccins on sera plus quoi en
faire
d'ici septembre l'on parle de 118
millions de doses
saucier à peu près pour vacciner quatre
fois tous les canadiens au pays et donc
il va y avoir ce débat d' qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ces doses excédentaires
est ce que ce sera surtout les
astrazeneca qu'on aura laissé de côté
est ce que c'est c'est là qu'on voit
renvoyer 20 les pays
- développer par exemple parce qu'une
question éthique par rapport à part à sa
très bientôt ce sera au sol des beaux
arts à mon ego bon alors à monsieur
trudeau on a posé la question
aujourd'hui est ce que la résurgence de
kankan le britannique en ontario où
dante allemand vous freine et vous vous
fait que vous allez mettre de côté des
scénarios d'élections printanières ou ou
d'été voici sa réponse
ce que ce serait responsable d'avoir des
élections ce printemps faut se rappeler
que notre démocratie est forte et on va
pouvoir se débrouiller mais c'est
certain que moi ma préférence est de
pouvoir continuer à travailler
directement pour les canadiens en tant
que gouvernement nous restons concentrés
là dessus
évidemment ça prend un parlement qui
continuent à fonctionner mais j'ai de
l'espoir que c'est la priorité aussi des
autres parties de travailler pour les
canadiens et non pour leurs fins
politiques
j'aime beaucoup l'image quand on dit ça
c'est une c'est une oeuvre
impressionniste on y voit ce qu'on veut
y voir un certain qu'il déjà pas fermé
la porte dont 18 à fermer la porte tour
de table martin généralement campagne tu
veux tout prévoir les policiers du
message l'heure n'est gagné leurs débats
quant à une pandémie puis tu regarde
aujourd'hui qu'à 30 % d'augmentation de
spécialisation notariaux se demande
comment il va faire campagne alors tout
peut dérailler
ça reste fragile et je suis pas certain
s'il voulait vraiment fermer la porte il
aurait pu le faire au lieu de les mettre
l'occasion de le faire il ne le fait pas
ce qu'il dit moi qu'ils se gardent cette
option mais j'avoue que je commence à me
tiédir à cette perspective
je ne sens pas là la fébrilité
préélectorale il faut dire qu'on
travaille de la maison c'est beaucoup
plus difficile à alpes et ça monte vite
une chèvre des fois oui sociale réussie
qu'on va attendre le budget mais je fais
juste noté que le projet de loi 16 19 le
qui est exposé de changer la loi
électorale pour permettre de tenir une
élection à pandémie n'a pas avancé d'un
pouce à la chambre des communes sera pas
prêt à temps pour cette éventuelle
élection printanière
bon j'ai peut-être pas fermé la fin de
michel mais disons que c'est pas loin
n'est ce pas on n'entend plus beaucoup
de cartes à mes lecteurs alors qu'il ya
trois semaines on l'entendait beaucoup
alors ça c'est un produit des choses la
deuxième regardez ce qui est arrivé à
terre-neuve
d'abord le fiasco de l'élection elle
même c'est peut-être parce qu'ils
veulent et qui arrive
l'autre chose une troisième vague
peut-être déjà très fâché de voir que le
premier se déclencher une élection car
même et d'autre part nos clients pas que
internet c'est un nouveau chef avec un
vieux chef d'opposition qu'il va y avoir
deux sièges
peut-être que je te dirais pas ça très
bien avant on n'en parle plus jusqu'au
budget
donnons nous sommes coincés par les
dures leçons
merci beaucoup à vous trois endroits à
voir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d